terry you just pulled two doubles you
must be tired
i'll stay for this whitman debacle you
go home i'm not tired why would you
think i was tired
i ended up doing 25 minutes of sleep
chin ups on muscle memory alone
tired terry still gets after it that's
all i'm saying
[Music]
we've busted murderers we've taken down
cartels but today we face the worst new
york has to offer
the fire department
fire marshall boone we meet again
detective peralta your flies down it
made you look i didn't look and i'm
wearing shorts there is no fly that's
not what your mom said you make no sense
and now i'm inside your head prepare to
die
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you don't have to dance every time true
but i choose the day every time
you have one play you give the ball to
jeffords and he runs it in i i'd like to
see you score one good because you're
about to see it
you're about to see it straight to hell
[Music]
come on push it push it
[Applause]
five
oh man
this is almost too easy are you crying
no that's eyeball sweat all right let's
wrap this up i gotta call sharon and get
back to work no no no hey i thought you
said
this was gonna be a challenge huh it's
been a cakewalk so far
oh you want me to make this harder
yes
that is what i want more harder exercise
look sarge
i burned 200 calories that's your heart
rate yeah that checks out come on jake
ten more minutes
i think we should stop now peralta no no
i'm still good
check this out right hook
right hook the uppercut
my arms don't seem to be responding to
my brain anymore
you sure you can lift this much weight
are you kidding me i was the strongest
kid in my camp seven summers in a row it
would have been eight if that freak
rebecca lobelman hadn't showed up let's
put in work
here we go one and i'm done that's it
oh good rep don't get too bulky
two things first this jim's wipe down
policies criminally lacks so i rewrote
it second i lowered the temperature of
the water fountain by two degrees still
waiting on feedback but i see a lot of
refresh faces
on behalf of captain holt florgasm
[Music]
[Music]
did you like it it was inspired by the
city of new york and that i stole it
from some kids i saw dancing on the
subway station all of you go home
immediately i was a little kid
i spent hours reading those books whoa
little terry did not see that coming
i was overweight and lonely and i wrote
dc parlov for advice and he sent me this
i hope it's not a severed head
the skyfire cycle sand into glass the
reckoning of kalar man that is a long
book is the rest of it just more of the
title it's the book that started it all
okay and listen to the inscription he
wrote
terry
you do have friends
you have me never forget that in this
life
we write our own stories
parlo
and that's what happened
little terry wrote his own story yeah a
little terry got buffa little terry got
emotionally healthy yeah and jacked you
know what
he didn't get jacked way to go little
terry
big back's coming through ah
there we go the jimmy jab game yeah
the first jimmy jabs were held in 2008
when the king of iraq president iran
armin jimmy jab ahmadinejad came to new
york and we were on call for nine
glorious hours in case there were
protests on that day a young genius
named jake peralta used the last piece
of his bagel to create the first jimmy
jab event
the monster mouth bagel toss
[Music]
and the rest was history as soon as hold
and terry leave we will commence with
jimmy jabs seven
circus of fools
now i believe i owe you a thousand
push-ups i don't care about the push-ups
jake i care that you didn't honor our
pact i've always trusted you and when
you did that it made me feel like you
don't trust me i know and i'm sorry it
won't happen again no it won't
now go down on the floor what you just
said you didn't care about the push-ups
i changed my mind
fair enough
tax-packed
one
two
three
damn it boyle you left the fridge open
the door couldn't shut because of your
empty pizza box pizza please this is a
butternut squash and truffle butter
flatbread everything's spoiled my lunch
is ruined
my chicken
my potatoes
my pasta my meatballs
pam
my yogurt
a lot of yogurt i love yogurt so this is
your lunch for like the month i need to
eat 10 000 calories a day to maintain
muscle mass my wife made me all of this
before she left town with the kids that
was everything in my fridge
scully hey yo serge i know you got a
secret stash of food hidden somewhere oh
no where is it no i don't is it in your
pocket oh come on i'm going to shake it
out of your pockets turn around sorry
go live scully oh
this is fun release you're sweet yes
lunch time wait's over that was easy
totally i feel like we just had our
snack an hour and 17 minutes ago i never
got into diets
though i did take diet pills in the 70s
i love these pills
they give me so much energy
and i can eat whatever i want
oh god
he's dead
actually i was in a coma
when i woke up i had so much mail
weight loss science has come a long way
since then
ingredients
carrot
gotta respect it ah
damn gina what is that oh it's a sloppy
jessica mac and cheese chili pizza on a
bun it's everything i've wanted to eat
for the last 48 hours
[Music]
what happened
i thought you were gonna last forever
[ __ ] turns out i gave up easy you
hear that [ __ ] i gave up so easy
again sarge it's so good to see you uh
just out of curiosity how did you find
out about this i'm a detective sergeant
in the nypd
ho told me why are you cutting me out of
the operation what that's crazy boyle
come in here and stand in front of my
body and tell him that's crazy ow my
lucky face you gonna talk to me now uh
sure uh if you could be any vacation oh
you didn't let me finish
if you could be any vacation what would
you be i'd be skiing oh no i'm gonna hit
you for real that wasn't for real oh my
god no wait wait wait i was worried
worried about what about you getting
hurt
i don't want your daughters growing up
without a dad i know what that's like
and it sucks and i don't want it to
happen to them why did you just say
something to me because i didn't want to
get in your head and have you freak out
again
you know i get it
it's been a rough year but i've learned
to embrace my fears it makes me a better
cop attacks one and two are set 30
minutes until the bogeys arrive thanks
boyle i love it when you say bogeys
so we good we good
oh and for the record
if i could be any kind of vacation
i'd be late trip classic
hey
terry
you get my email
about how i was coming down here no i
haven't checked my phone ah
no need i just wanted to make sure
you're here you know you know how i like
to have a weight mate really i have
never seen you in the gym what i
basically live here i'm a regular jim
dandy besides i gotta get into shape for
all the godfathering i'm gonna do i mean
how am i gonna throw our baby up into
the air with these noodle arms good
point so take me through your workout
man
rip me up you know let's rip it out time
to rip it down those aren't gym terms
and i don't think you can handle my
workout oh wow sounds like a challenge
to me
come on
give it here
i gotcha ready yep oh i got so heavy
sarge what are you doing
see
i'm fine
what is happening just to tell me gurgle
damn messed up my sister
oh no um
[Music]
you